Today, we're diving into a
single law that for decades
built a kind of firewall to keep
the US government's foreign
messaging away from its own
people.
It's called the Smith Mundact,
and honestly, understanding it
is key to making sense of our
media world today.
So let's just cut right to the
chase with a really direct
question.
Can the US government legally
aim propaganda at you, an
American citizen?
For a very, very long time, the
answer was a simple and clear
no.
But that's changed.
And the story of how we got from
no to, well, it's complicated,
is what we're going to unpack.
For more than 60 years, that
answer was a hard no.
But then came 2013, when a
little known change to the law
basically rewrote the rule book.
To really get a grip on what
that change means, we have to go
back to when the original rule
was first put in place.
So let's talk about this idea of
a propaganda firewall.
This wasn't a real wall, of
course.
It was a legal wall built right
after World War 2 for a very,
very specific reason.
And here it is, the Smith Munde
Act of 1948.
It was designed to do 2 things.
First, it gave the government
the green light to engage in
what's called public diplomacy
overseas, you know, spreading
messages about American culture
and values.
But the second part, and this is
the crucial bit, is that it
strictly prohibited that same
stuff from being aimed at the
American public.
Now, the fear driving this law
was fresh.
It came straight out of the
experience of World War 2.
Lawmakers had just seen how
incredibly powerful state-run
propaganda could be with
broadcasters like Japan's Tokyo
Rose or Nazi Germany's Lord Haha
using the radio to try and crush
Allied morale.
The whole point of Smith Munt
was to let America compete in
that global arena of ideas while
making damn sure that powerful
tool could never be turned back
on its own people.
So what did this No propaganda
at Home Rule actually look like
in the real world?
How did this firewall work day
in and day out?
The dividing line was purely
based on geography.
It was actually pretty simple.
The government's international
radio station, Voice of America,
could broadcast deep into the
Soviet Union no problem, but it
was literally illegal for that
same programming to be aired in
Kansas.
US embassies could hand out
pamphlets on democracy in other
countries, but they could not
distribute those same pamphlets
in Los Angeles.
The line was drawn right at the
US sport.
So the fundamental idea was
this.
Anything the State Department or
other agencies made to influence
people overseas was treated like
it was for export only.
It was kept separate behind a
sturdy bureaucratic wall, and
for decades, this system
actually held up.
But then a technology came along
that has absolutely no respect
for geography.
The Internet didn't just weaken
the firewall, it shattered it.
This created what people started
calling the boomerang effect.
A video produced by the US
government for an audience in
Afghanistan could get uploaded
to YouTube, and in an instant,
someone in Cleveland could be
watching it.
The law was built on borders,
but the Internet makes borders
meaningless.
The firewall was full of holes.
You can really see the whole
story unfold right here on this
timeline.
In 48 the firewall goes up
through the Cold War.
EU gets really good at rojecting
the soft power with outlets like
Radio Free Europe.
But then the 2000s hit, and the
Internet just makes that wall
orous.
And that all leads to the big
moment in 2013 when the
Modernization Act officially
takes down the domestic ban.
Which brings us to today, a
completely borderless
information war fought on all of
our screens.
Now, the debate over making this
change was intense.
On one side, you had supporters
arguing that the old rule was
just obsolete, totally
pointless.
In the Internet age.
They'd say, look, this material
is already getting back into the
US anyway.
Removing the ban just makes it
transparent and honest.
But opponents saw it very, very
differently.
They were afraid that this would
open the floodgates legally
allowing the government to point
its massive messaging apparatus
right at its own people.
And in July of 2013, the change
was made.
The Smith Mont Modernization Act
went into effect, and just like
that, the 65 year old ban on
domestic dissemination was
officially over.
So that brings us to right now.
We are living in a brand new
borderless information war, and
it's worth asking why this
seemingly obscure legal tweak
matters so much to us today.
The reason governments create
all this content comes down to
this idea of soft power.
This isn't about military might
or economic punishments.
It's about a country's ability
to shape what other people want
through attraction and
persuasion.
It's about winning hearts and
minds, and it's a critical tool
in international politics.
And let's be crystal clear, the
United States is far from the
only one playing this game.
It's a global phenomenon.
The UK has its legendary BBC
World Service, Russia has RT,
China has CGTN.
For decades, every major world
power has run its own
international media outlets to
project its influence and its
version of the story.
So really the bottom line is
that using information as a tool
of the state is universal.
It's just part of the modern
political toolkit.
The only real difference between
nations is how transparent they
choose to be about what they're
doing.
I think the best way to picture
this whole shift is with this
analogy.
Think of U.S. government funded
media before 2013 as export only
beer.
It was brewed to be sold
overseas and you just couldn't
buy it here.
After 2013, that export only
label was removed.
Now that same beer is available
on the domestic shelf.
And what's the result of all
this?
The line that once clearly
separated government made
content for foreign eyes from
the domestic news that you and I
consume.
Well, that line has now been
officially and permanently
blurred.
Which leaves us all with one
final, and I think really
important question.
The old law built that firewall
to shield citizens.
That firewall is now gone.
So in a world where information
flows everywhere instantly
Without Borders, who is
responsible for building the
firewall now?